Hello. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm
Robert Krulwich dishes radiolab.
This hour we're going to talking about
diagnosis, diagnosis, the easy kind.
We're not going to talk about it.
Easy would be you come into my office
and I'm a doctor. You have a broken arm.
I take a picture. I say, Hey, you've
got a broken arm. That picture says so.
Yeah, cause you can see
the break right there.
But let's suppose you came into
my office and you were sad.
You tell me that your sex drive
is down. Yay. I'm the doctor.
So we're going to sit. But just
between you and me, right? Well,
right away my learning tells me that
you may be a candidate for depression,
but how do I know that you're
depressed? What do you mean?
How do we know we talk
about it? You just said,
well you can't measure
sadness or depression.
You can't go to a test tube
and count anything. Right.
It's not hard science.
Yeah, because till now,
what if I put you in, you know,
one of those FMR I machines that
we've talked about so often?
I snap a picture of your brain in action
and I look at it and from your picture
I say that you are depressed. You're
going to tell me I'm depressed.
Just from looking at a picture of
my brain. Yes. What? No Way. Look,
it's now here. Photographic diagnosis
of mental illness. This is happening.
There is no question and that by the way,
is Eric Candela professor up at Columbia
University who just happens to have won
the Nobel prize for medicine. Let me
give you a little historical back.
Did you get a note, Bill? I don't think
you did. I still don't believe you.
And what just cause he's got a Nobel
prize. I'm going to suddenly turn it.
Oh no you're not. So let's do
this step by step. Okay. Step one.
Imagine you're slipping
into an FMR I machine. Okay.
I want you to just look at my
face. Why is that so difficult?
Just to know what this
is going anywhere. Okay.
I'm looking at your face now
that you're looking at my face.
Different regions of the
brain, they become active.
There are cells in your brain
that are saying, I know him.
The cells are more active. They need
energy. Just like when you're running,
you have to breathe fast and to get the
energy, your heart pumps more blood.
The body sends a rush of fresh blood with
that particular group of cells because
the blood has iron in it.
The magnet and the brain scanner can
see the iron and therefore see the blood
field and take pictures of it. Many,
many pictures in real time. I'll
show you a very nice example of that.
Eric's now heading off across his ample
office with an extraordinary view of the
Hudson Valley and he brought over a
picture of a human brain with different
colors in different areas and he
told me, when you look at a face,
when you image the face,
this area lights up.
You're pointing to an area of
your main area of the brain,
your on your forehead kind
of. That's right. That's fine.
If you look at a house,
some other area lights up,
but this area does not light
up. You look at another face.
This area lights up again. Every time
you see a face, the same area. Yup.
But you haven't told me anything
about emotions yet. That's true.
So let's move on to step two
because we use faces to tell what
someone else's thinking or someone else's
feeling.
Looking at faces also triggers an area
deep in the brain that is concerned with
the emotion called the Amygdala.
Now very recently a number of people
have looked at the make the looking at
faces and it's extremely
interesting. Step three.
Okay, I'm going to take you now to
London. Hello. Hi. Yeah, hi. Yeah,
that's good. It's okay. Who is
this? Oh wait, sorry. Who are you?
I'm Cynthia [inaudible].
My psychiatrist at
the Institute of Psychiatry
Kings College London.
And Are you liking your 30s or your
forties or your 50s this is part of the
interview I want cause like
cause your mood tonight man.
I wanted to establish that she came
into psychiatry. Trying to think,
when did I graduate medical school.
I didn't live very critical time.
I finished my training in 97 my training
in psychiatry in 97 1997 when the Fmri
machines were first becoming available.
And so Cynthia was able to
do a rather amazing study.
What in this study she got together
a group of people who were clinically
depressed, depressed people, and then
another group of people who are normal,
healthy people and she put them in the
brain scan machine and showed them facial
expressions,
faces ranging from more neutral
expressions to more sad expressions.
So they saw a sad face and then a neutral
face and a sad face. That's right.
And what the person in the machine was
supposed to do is look at these faces and
decide whether it was a
man or a woman's face. Huh?
What does that have to do
with anything? Because,
because while they were doing that,
now they're making this decision.
The emotion of the face is
being processed automatically.
The amygdala sees the emotion on the
faces at that moment and the machines,
it's like tick, tick, tick, tick, tick.
And they were hundreds of pictures.
10th of a second to 10th of a second.
A 10th of a second. That's right.
Did you see a difference between the
people who were depressed and the people
who were normal? Yes.
Was it a significant difference or adjust?
Barely difference as a group it was a
significant difference and now she takes
the big step.
Step four from the pattern
she sees in bunches of people,
she feeds all those patterns into
a computer called machine learning.
Show the program. This is a pattern of
brain activity and depressed people.
This is a pattern and brain
activity in healthy people.
And then she shows the computer
a brain scan of a new person.
So this is someone the computer's
never met before. Exactly.
And she did this a bunch of time,
right? A whole bunch of people.
And each time the computer tries to get,
is this new person depressed
or not? Oh and what?
What happened? More than 85% of the time,
86% of the time the algorithm
correctly diagnosed,
whether that person was
depressed or healthy.
[inaudible]
was just a brain scan, a computer
and a patient. No doctor.
Cynthia's computer got
the diagnosis right.
86% of the time a computer. Let me
saw the results. It's like, wow,
this is amazing. Wait a second.
Has she repeated this? Well,
this is actually the very first time that
this has been done with depression and
so it's just a pilot
study and like you say,
someone else will have to do
it again and again and again,
but according [inaudible] does,
Cynthia, the potential is fantastic.
Psychiatry is going to be
absolutely revolutionize.
I think this method can be applied
to any psychiatric disorder,
any autism. It's a phrenia obsessive
compulsive disorder. No Way. Come on.
Why not?
Every one of these illnesses ultimately
must have an anatomical basis,
every one of these illnesses,
so this means that it will shoot or one
day be possible for a patient to come in
and you take a picture of him in real
time or of her and you will have a
diagnostic tool. That's what
you're saying? Absolutely.
Absolutely.
You mean to tell me that they're going
to put people in machines and just go
boom, no, no, no. Wait, wait, wait.
This is not a casual thing.
You go to the doctor,
you tell the doctor that
you're feeling a certain way,
the doctor will talk to you and
then he would come to you and say,
well my learning and the test
tells me that you're ill.
So that's all it's happening. Share is
now the medical doctor was habitats.
We have nothing in this
that feels invasive to you.
Well obviously huddling into the deep
depths of your personhood is no, this is,
if you believe that mental
illness is a mental illness,
it is a structural condition
which can be fixed.
So it's not the deep inner
you, it's the broken you.
So it's like the broken arms
and you started off with that.
So you would put the two side
by side. I think I would.
And then of course you get to
the Nelson. Come on Robert.
I mean human beings are
way too messy for that.
You're too messy for it to
be that easy. No, no way.
So you think this is out of science's
reach? Really? It's just too,
there's a part of me that does
think it is out of science.
I think it's because you think you think
that they're looking deep inside you.
That's what you don't like. I
do. I mean, don't get me wrong.
I find brain scans fascinating when it
comes to questions like where is the
salt? What is consciousness?
That kind of stuff,
but don't kind of get in my head and
tell me what's what's right and what's
wrong and sick. Don't you
want to get better? Yes,
but I enjoy the comfortable ambiguity
that would come from a situation like
sitting in a therapist's office and
saying, well, I'm, how am I feeling?
I'm feeling this way or that way.
And in the messiness of trying to
just rely on how you're feeling,
there's a vast landscape of, of
things that can happen. Choices.
You can make therapies,
you can pursue it this way.
Let's say you are sick and you know
that you're sick machine or no. Okay.
[inaudible] if you are feeling badly,
wouldn't it be nice if a machine could
help you find the right kind of help?
What do you mean? Well, Eric took me
people to do a thought experiment,
a mind experiment.
You've developed a psychotherapy
and I've developed a psychotherapy.
We each claim it's the best in the world.
Now we have an objective way of seeing
this machine allows you to independently
of any evaluation, see
the outcome of treatment.
So you can audit the doctor,
audit the doctor and give you evidence
that it's working or no. Okay.
[inaudible] a little bit on board.
I can give you 10% buy in now. Okay,
so how far off is this stuff?
Is it going to come soon?
This is very early in the game, obviously,
but I get to ask him like how far into
the future are we talking about here?
Soon or mid after long after you're dead.
I'm going to be around a long time,
but the question stands, will you
make it to see that said, look,
people who actually have you
don't. One can't in medicine.
In all honesty, give a timeline
for many of these things.
Imaging methodology right
now is quite sophisticated,
but it's still primitive
compared where it needs to be.
You're picking this up in
status and this entity,
you become excited as the
thing is beginning to emerge.
We see it for the first
time on the horizon.
You saying we got to the story too
early. That's what you said, just right.
It's not going to be interesting.
20 years from now it'll be obvious.
Or in 20 years it'll be obvious
that we were wrong. Okay.
That's a real possibility because what
we don't know is ally's vast. Yeah,
and I want to tell you a story now about
just how wrong people can be. Okay.
It begins with a mystery,
sudden infant death syndrome,
perfectly healthy child goes to
sleep and dies during the night.
[inaudible]
it's about the worst thing that can
happen to a parent and each year it does
happen about 7,000 times. It's still,
no one knows why. Oh, and by the way,
that was Robert Sapolsky.
He's a professor of neuroscience
at Stanford University,
and a Spolsky tells this story of the
moment sids was diagnosed for the first
time,
or at least classified in a terrible
mistake that was made around 1900 or so.
People were being made to recognize
this as a disease entity and nobody knew
what was up. So people
decided, let's go dissect sids.
Kids meaning when a baby would die, they
would perform an autopsy. Exactly, yes.
Checked the baby's inside.
See if there's anything different in them
from normal kids. That seems logical.
Absolutely.
They measure the size of the baby's
lungs. Yep. Normal. And they didn't.
They measured the size of the heart.
Yep. Nothing strange. Their stomach,
kidney, liver, Yep. Those are all fine.
Then they would look in the throat.
[inaudible]
they look in there and they
say, oh my God, these sids kids,
they have enormous fine. This
glance, the thymus of famous.
What is the famous wonder? Well,
it is a little tiny pink
gland that is right there.
Right behind your collarbone,
Huh? At the base of your throat.
And Its job is to help you fight disease
makes one type of cell critical to your
immune system, especially
in times of stress.
Any case,
normally this little organ is about
the size of a tiny tube of toothpaste,
like the tribal coin. But in these
six kids it was huge. Humongous,
enormous. Twice the size. Exactly.
And since the thymus is
dangerously close to the windpipe,
doctors came up with a hypothesis,
perfectly reasonable hypothesis,
which was that maybe if you're one of
these babies with an enlarged thymus and
you're asleep and somehow you roll over
wrong [inaudible] well that gland might
press down on your trachea and
suffocate you during the night. Oh, so
medical mystery soft, really? Nope.
They even came up with a name for
it. It was called status find Maco,
lymphatic and the spillage.
It was in all the pediatric textbooks
by the 1920s and you would look in there
and there'd be pictures, there would be
pictures of the dissector fine misses,
normal size. And here
on the right in large,
abnormally large status find the
colon fat. And in no time at all,
doctors came up with a treatment,
perfectly logical therapy,
which is that if we're
going to help these babies,
we've got to shrink their
thymus gland. And to do that,
the best solution obviously is to
irradiate their throats or radiate their
throats to shrink their thymus gland
that the child's throat with
trillions of radioactive particles.
You literally, you Betcha.
And this was considered like something
every good loving parents should do.
Absolutely. If you worry about
your child being at risk for sids,
go and get their throats irradiated to
shrink the thymus glands and did it work?
Yes. Shrank the following. Ms Glanz.
But he says it did have another effect.
Decades later. You've killed 20 to
30,000 people with thyroid cancer.
20 30,000 deaths. That's a, that's
a real number. Yeah, that's a,
that's a fairly big one.
Yeah. So here's my question.
How could these doctors have
gotten it so, so, so, so, so wrong.
Do you know what I mean? I do.
I don't. You know what you mean?
You just answered your own question
a minute ago. No, no, I didn't.
I'm about to answer it right now.
They're playing with radiation.
You just said that. But what they, what?
They didn't know that radiation would
hurt you. They had no, it was like,
that's not technology,
but that's not what I was
[inaudible]
no, a couple of decades into
radiation having been discussed,
isotopes are performing near
miracles of diagnosis and discovery.
Well, we're just tossing around
radiation all over the place. Yeah.
Iodine one 31 radioactive sodium
right off gamma rays. Blue Trot.
And this was a period with madame
Curie dipping her arm into vats of
radioactivity. Harmless in dying.
Soon afterwards from cancer,
people would go into shoe stores and
they would have their feet x-ray. Yes.
X-Ray is a wonderful invention I
had that you had that. I did. Yes.
Kick off your shoes. And I think
you can look at your balloon.
That's exactly what that, how would
you do that? That's what that was back.
That was the thing you could do at
the shoe store was very cool. Good.
Showing how cutting edge of
a shoe store or they aren't.
So that's your explanation. Yeah. So
that may look like the explanation,
meet your radiation would play
a role. But if you would have,
let me say what I was gonna say. I would
have told you the real explanation.
Yes. Preceded the radiation by like a
couple hundred years. Hello? I don't know,
idea what you're talking. I'm going to
tell you back in the 17 hundreds okay.
Oh, that far back, that far back
before, uh, radiation before, uh,
your grandpa for, uh,
before the civil war or the
Eiffel tower in Napoleon.
I'm talking when the red coats
were still wearing red. Yeah. Yeah.
This was shortly after the revolutionary
war, right about this time.
So supposedly the first med schools
exist, started to pop up in America,
and a supply and demand issue came into
effect because with these med schools
came med students, medical students
who needed to learn about anatomy.
And of course, in order to do
that, they needed bodies, you know,
to dissect this, produced
this whole occupation.
You could be a resurrection
list or resurrect Janice. Yup.
And they would go out and
dig up bodies that's at night
and sell them to the unanimous
just the medical schools.
I'll need two more by Thursday.
[inaudible] yeah. Hey Dick.
Now here's the key point.
Since demand was so high,
the resurrection has had to go where
the bodies were easiest to get,
which meant no, avoiding
the fancy graveyards.
If you were wealthy,
you could have yourself buried in
what was called a patent coffin,
which was a triple layer coffin, which
was meant to be. Resurrection is proof,
but if you are not wealthy,
no fancy coffin for you,
you'd probably just be buried in a sack
and some poppers field just a few inches
under the soil. Very accessible
for these resurrection lists.
Not surprisingly, that's where they went.
Are we still on the same topic? Are you
explaining why children die? Yes, yes,
they're with me. All right.
What I'm trying to make is that the grave
robbers targeted the poor so much so
sometimes when they, you know,
people would catch these resurrection
lists in the act and see like, oh my God,
that's my dad. You're digging
up [inaudible] there'd be riots.
Stop stealing
leaps recalled out and
why odors were shot.
Are we talking like hundreds
of people torch bearing a,
it was townies versus the people who are
trying to dissect their dead relatives.
This is a lot of history and
I'm very fascinated in quotes.
What does this have to do with kids
dying? Fire, right? Let me bring it home.
Not that it hasn't been interesting,
but being at home, okay.
As a result of all of this hubbub over
a grave robbing country after country
throughout Europe decided,
no, let's standardize how
science gets it's cadavers.
Forget all this great robbing.
So they passed laws which formalized
anyone who died in a poorhouse,
uh, their body would be
turned over to the anatomist.
This was like the cadaver
version of direct deposit. Okay.
So grave robbing was gone,
but now all the body's use by
medicine and not just some,
but nearly all now came from the poor
estimates were by the end of that century,
99% of the body's used for,
for anatomy lessons had been
derived from poor houses.
And that seemed okay until 1936 a guy
named Han Soviet showed that being poor
actually warps your body. And now Robert,
now we come back to the case of the
mysteriously enlarged time is cause if
you're poor, you're either
worried about your job,
you're worried about feeding your
family, you're worried about the bills.
In other words, you are stressed
out during chronic stress.
Your immune system goes down the tubes
and since the time is this part of the
immune system, if you are chronically
stressed, the thymus gland shrinks.
Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad and
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
This hour we're going to talking about
diagnosis, diagnosis. The easy card,
we're not going to talk about it easy
would be you come into my office and I'm a
doctor. You have a broken arm.
I take a picture. I say, Hey,
you've got a broken arm.
That picture says so. Yeah,
cause you can see the break right there.
But let's suppose you came into
my office and you were sad.
You tell me that your sex drive
is down. Yay. I'm the doctor.
So we're going to sit. But
just between you and me. Well,
right away my learning tells me that
you may be a candidate for depression,
but how do I know that you're
depressed? What do you mean?
How do we know we talk
about it? You just said,
well you can't measure
sadness or depression.
You can't go to a test tube
and count anything. Right?
It's not hard science.
Yeah. Because till now,
what if I put you in, you know,
one of those FMR AI machines that
we've talked about so often? Yeah.
I snap a picture of your brain in action
and I look at it and from your picture
I say that you are depressed. You're
going to tell me I'm depressed.
Just from looking at a picture of
my brain. Yes. What? No Way. Look,
it's now here. Photographic diagnosis
of mental illness. This is happening.
There is no question, and that,
by the way, is Eric Kandel,
a professor up at Columbia University
who just happens to have won the Nobel
prize for medicine. Let me give
you a little historical backwards.
Did you get a note.